of this special TV offer.
>> THE DEBATE OVER SCHOOL
REOPENING CENTERS AROUND
VACCINES AND SAFETY FOR INSIGHT
INTO THE MEDICAL ISSUES
INVOLVED IN THIS DEBATE WILL
BRING IN INFECTIOUS DISEASE
EXPERT AND JOHNS HOPKINS
SCHOLAR, DOCTOR, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
AS YOU KNOW, C.D.C. DIRECTOR
WALENSKY SAID THIS WEEK THAT
THE DATA IS POINTING TO THE
FACT THAT NOT EVERY TEACHER
NEEDS TO BE VACCINATED IN ORDER
FOR SCHOOLS TO BE GOING TO
IN-PERSON LEARNING.
AND THAT WAS WALKED BACK SAYING
THAT THE DOCTOR WAS SPEAKING IN
HER PERSONAL CAPACITY.
I WANT FOLKS TO SEE THE TWEET
YOU PUT UP.
IN RESPONSE TO THAT.
YOU WROTE THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD STAND BY
THE SCIENCE THAT THEIR C.D.C.
DIRECTOR BASED HER COMMENTS ON
AND POLITICIANS AND
SPOKESPERSON TRYING TO
UNDERMINE HER INTELLECT AND WAS
IN HER PERSONAL CAPACITY WAS
WRONG.
WHAT DO YOU SAY THAT PARENTS
SHOULD TAKE FROM THIS LESS THAN
CLEAR MESSAGE COMING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION?
>> WHAT I THINK PARENTS SHOULD
THINK ABOUT IS LOOKING AT THE
DATA THAT WE’RE SEEING FROM
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE OPENED AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND ALL AROUND THE
WORLD, IN TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
IS A SCHOOL A FOCUS FOR
TRANSMISSION, THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT, NOT THE SPORTS, NOT
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITY AND I
THINK THAT THE DATA SHOWS THAT
SCHOOLS CAN BE OPEN SAFELY WITH
CERTAINLY SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE
AND CAPACITY RESTRICTIONS AND
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND IT’S
IMPORTANT FOR VULNERABLE
TEACHERS, THOSE FALLING IN THE
HIGH RISK GROUPS TO BE
VACCINATED, BUT IT SHOULDN’T BE
A REREQUISITE TO OPEN SCHOOLS.
WE’VE OPENED SCHOOLS IN PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY WITHOUT TEACHERS
BEING VACCINATED.
I DON’T WANT VACCINATIONS TO BE
AN OBSTACLE TO OPENING SCHOOLS.
WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN ARE
SUFFERING AND THAT IT CAN BE
DONE SAFELY.
AND THE C.D.C. DIRECTOR AND THE
C.D.C. DIRECTOR BEFORE HER
STATED IT CAN BE DONE SAFELY.
I THINK IT SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY.
SCHOOLS SHOULD BE THE FIRST
THINGS TO OPEN AND THE LAST TO
CLOSE.
THAT’S WHAT PEOPLE LIKE DR.
FAUCI, DR. WALENSKY, DR.
REDFIELD HAVE SAID.
TO OPEN UP BASED ON THE
EPIDEMIOLOGY, BASED ON THE
SCIENCE.
ALICIA: HOW MUCH DOES THIS TYPE
OF DISAGREEMENT THAT’S
HAPPENING IN PUBLIC IMPACT THE
TIMELINE OF SCHOOLS ACTUALLY
OPENING UP IN PERSON?
DOES IT SLOW IT DOWN
SIGNIFICANTLY OR--
>> I THINK WE ARE GOING TO SEE
DIG DELAYS IN OPENING SCHOOLS.
SCHOOLS THAT ARE OPEN I THINK
WILL STAY OPEN.
I SEE IN GENERAL THE RHETORIC
IS CHANGING ESPECIALLY WITH THE
WAY THAT THE TEACHERS UNIONS
HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT
VACCINATION AS THEIR MAJOR
FACTOR TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL.
WE’RE SEEING OTHERS HAPPEN IN
MAJOR CITIES.
I THINK THERE’S PROBABLY GOING
TO BE A DELAY, I WISH THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD FOLLOW
WHAT THE C.D.C. DIRECTOR IS
SAYING AND NOT TRYING TO
DISCOUNT IT AS SOMETHING IN HER
PERSONAL CAPACITY.
AND THAT’S EXACTLY WHY SHE’S
C.D.C. DIRECTOR, HER APALNALYSIS
AS IS ON.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OPEN
WITHIN THE FIRST 1 #00 DAYS AND
I THINK IT’S DOABLE AND SHOULD
BE DONE.
ALICIA: AS WE SEE THIS UNFOLDS,
INCREASING VARIANTS COMING INTO
THE COUNTRY.
I WANT TO PUT UP SOME OF THE
INFORMATION ON THAT SO FOLKS
CAN TAKE A LOOK.
YOU HAVE THE U.K. VARIANT CASES
COMING IN, TWO FROM BRAZIL AND
SOUTH AFRICA AND THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF CASES IN THE UNITED
STATES RIGHT NOW, MORE THAN 26
MILLION.
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU IS HOW
CONCERNED SHOULD PEOPLE BE
ABOUT THIS VARIANT?
WHAT ARE THE DANGERS AND
DISTINCTIONS HERE THAT FOLKS
SHOULD KEEP IN MIND?
>> THESE VARIANT LIKELY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO TRANSFER MORE
EFFICIENTLY.
WE SHOULD BE MORE ABOUT HAND
WASHING AND MASK WEARING.
WE DON’T THINK IT’S MORE
DEADLY.
SOME OF THE VARIANTS, INCLUDING
AFRICAN AND BRAZIL VARIANT
SHOULD BE FOR EFFICACY, IF YOU
LOOK AT JOHNSON & JOHNSON AND
NOVA
NOVAVAX, IT’S ABILITY WAS
UNDETER.
YOU STILL GOT INFECTED AND YOU
DIDN’T GET THE SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES.
THAT’S THE MESSAGE,.
THAT MEANS THAT WE HAVE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH VACCINATION WITH
NO SPEED LIMIT AND GET VACCINES
INTO PEOPLE’S ARMS AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE AND THAT’S THE WAY